Future Trunks flashing onto the scene
out of nowhere taking out the most
prolific villain in Dragonball history
soon becoming one of the most popular
characters in the entire series however
with a saga that includes moments such
as this I often felt as though a
particular relationship dynamic was
largely kept out of the spotlight so as
I often do I decided to go to my Twitter
to ask my followers what they thought
asking the question which of these was
your favorite relationship in Dragon
Balls sellar I provided three options to
choose from and with over two thousand
votes cast the clear winner was Gohan
and Goku and while I think there are
definitely a lot of aspects to love
about the relationship and interactions
during this part of the story today I
want to bring attention to and focus on
or I believe is one of the most
underrated fantastic and believable
relationships ever told in Dragonball I
want to take an in-depth look at how
trunks and his scenes were written to
achieve an emotional connection with the
audience to explore how the supporting
characters played a role in reinforcing
this relationship and to explain how a
father and son dynamic builds one of the
most realistic and cathartic
relationships in the show's history this
is Future Trunks the wounded
[Music]
in storytelling what makes a character
and story interesting is largely the
conflict according to km ones book
creating character arcs there are four
aspects that make up the arc and the
conflict in a character's mind these are
the lie that they believe the thing they
want the thing they need and the wound
to begin our dissection of trunks is
character I think it's important we
first understand the storytelling term
wound
according to author km Wyland wound is
movie speak for something in your
character's past that haunts him often
the wound will be something shocking and
traumatic this wound from a traumatic
event typically causes or is connected
to the live the character believes which
is the harboring of some deeply held
misconception the character either
believes about themselves the world or
both
in other words the characters wound
often goes hand in hand with the lie
that they believe and need to overcome
over the course of the story for example
in the case of Marvel's spider-man
homecoming Peters wound is his Uncle
Ben's murder it's something he blames
himself for something that drives him
throughout the stories one time and
continues to do so today at the same
time the lie that he believes is that he
needs the suit to be spider-man that in
order to be a hero he needs that special
suit Tony Stark provided for him to
which Tony Stark responds if you're
nothing without this shoe then you
shouldn't have it okay in this one scene
Peter desire to help others is
demonstrated his wound Uncle Ben's death
motivating him but at the same time it's
made evident through his own words that
he doesn't fully believe in himself
which is the lie his character beliefs
in the case of trunks during his
unveiling he comes off as a confident
and capable fighter breezing through the
largest foe the series has seen in an
instant with a smirk on his face
however shortly after we soon find out
that he isn't as sure-footed as he
initially appeared we eventually learned
that trunks comes from an alternate
future where everyone but himself
Bulma and a few others have died the
individuals responsible the androids
Despicable cyborgs responsible for
taking trunks his only father figure
away from him Gohan
this is trunks is wound trunks blames
himself for Gohan's death and his
timeline if he had been stronger if he
had been better maybe he could have
saved him
as a result of this trauma the light
trunks now believes is that he needs
someone else to save his timeline for
him he needs help
additionally he deeply desires to meet
and build a relationship of some form
with the father he never had a chance to
meet which leads me nicely into what I
believe was trunks his most important
play in the series his interactions with
a certain character Samara Damiano the
Cheetahs wound or traumatic
life-changing event was his planets
destruction and his upbringing under
Frieza he was raised to believe that
strength was all that mattered and that
he was destined to be the strongest
Saiyan
however when he finds out that that
isn't the case suddenly becoming
stronger and demonstrating his
superiority becomes the only thing that
occupies his mind Vegeta now thinks that
the only thing worth pursuing his power
that is the lie that Vegeta believes and
he puts up a strong guard against those
that suggest otherwise however in trunks
his first conversation with Goku before
leaving to the past he comments that
Vegeta looks lonely
forms Goku that that was what made Bulma
interact with him in the first place
she had sympathy for Vegeta but that's
not to say trunks is perfect either this
is the terrific example of character
values in conflict in John troubies book
the anatomy of story he writes identify
a set of values for your hero and each
of the other main characters make each
set of values as different from the
others as possible as your hero and his
opponents fight over the goal make sure
their values come into direct conflict
in other words establish the theme of
your story set the main goal for all the
characters to aim for and give all the
characters pushing towards that goal
different values in the case of trunks
and Vegeta in this instance they are
working towards the same goal but have
vastly different ideas of what they
think it takes to achieve that goal when
the androids are woken up trunks
unleashes a massive blast without
warning after which Vegeta remarks that
that was an entirely pointless effort
which it was trunks believes that the
androids are too monstrous and that they
shouldn't even try he's ruled by fear
and vengeance clouding his judgment
leading to poor decisions being made
Vegeta on the other side of the coin
thinks that nothing can be greater than
he is and that if they are that strong
he should still be the one to face them
anyway these actions are motivated by
the wounds both characters have endured
in their pasts resulting in them both
living out the lies that they hold to be
true trunks ruled by fear of loss and
destruction deems it impossible to win
without help and Vegeta believing only
he can do it refusing any help however
something happens during Vegeta's fight
with 18 trunks remarks I never knew my
father was so powerful he's holding his
own against those androids androids we
later find out are tougher than those in
trunks his timeline trunks
underestimates what he and others are
capable of because of his fear and
experiences however by that same token
Vegeta overestimates what he is capable
of casting aside the notion of ever
working as part of a team it's worth
mentioning at this point that trunks was
correct in his estimations of the
Android
that alone Vegeta was no match for a
teen once his stamina was drained
however his estimation of what a Saiyan
as capable of was skewed by fear and
when faced with another father figure
down one arm on the brink of death
trunks acts on emotion making matters
worse by including Android 17 trunks is
naive but he doesn't know it yet
Vegeta makes a lot of mistakes but he
never makes the mistake of under
estimating what he is capable of as
mentioned by both piccolo and Goku in
this arc Vegeta is a fighting genius
demonstrating a mental toughness and
resilience that trunks is sorely lacking
perfectly shown by their first reactions
to the inside of the time chamber with
trunks distraught and Vegeta delighted
due to the trauma of trunks is past and
his belief that he needs help to succeed
he can't clearly take stock of what he
is capable of when that is all that
Vegeta can see clearly above himself now
locked in a room together Vegeta is
forced to share a space with his son and
trunks is forced to challenge his limits
in ways he never thought possible the
lies they tell themselves are almost
perfect opposites trunks wants group
cooperation but doesn't believe it
himself Vegeta believes only in himself
and wants nothing to do with teamwork
both of their lives are in direct
conflict and as a result they force each
other to change
[Music]
the positive change arc sees the
protagonist start out with varying
degrees of denial and suffering as the
story progresses he's forced to
challenge his beliefs above both himself
and the world around him until finally
overcoming these inner demons changing
for the better
Vegeta realizes in this moment that he
does care about other people he cares
about his son
despite being uncaring and unkind to the
Past he dashes in to avenge his son in
the same careless manner trunks stood
against Android 18 this was not a smart
move
when Vegeta apologizes for moments later
however to complete his arc for this
saga he works as part of a team to
defeat cell alongside Gohan playing the
supporting role thanks to trunks Vegeta
whether he wants to admit it now or not
cares that has grown as a character for
the better
trunks woods revived after all his
experience through his time with the
main cast has overcome his internal
struggle - he now believes that he has
what it takes to protect his future
again this is similar to the plot of
spider-man homecoming as Peter is seen
being crushed beneath a large and very
heavy object he cries out for help but
no one answers through his struggles in
the film he realizes that the help Tony
gave him didn't make him spider-man he
is and always has been
spider-man and people are depending on a
Peter rising to the occasion utilizing
his wound as a motivation to overcome
his lie results in one of the most
moving and inspirational moments of the
film in that same wave Vegeta and the
rest of the supporting cast helped
motivate and improve trunks to the point
where he no longer needs help he can
take care of his world alone he always
had that ability or potential in him he
just couldn't see it he is no longer a
boy he is now a man there are tons of
famous father and son stories in fiction
where both characters address their
shortcomings and ultimately challenge
each other to be better in ways they
would never have been able to do alone
having given myself the time to reflect
upon the story that was told between
these two characters through this lens I
now see and better understand how
important this aspect of the narrative
was in creating the moments we all loved
and appreciated on the sir
thanks to the addition of trunks the
past traumas of both himself and Vegeta
were exposed and challenged for the
better ultimately forcing each other to
heal from their past traumas to
relinquish their lies they believed and
to adopt a new truth moving forward this
relationship is a complex tale full of
innocence hope pride and ultimately
catharsis and it's thanks to this father
and sons story we've learned that in
order to heal you need to call attention
to and address the wounded characters
thanks for watching
you